blessing which is turkish
in the middle
[music]
can
do others know the problems recognize
solution
that means just accept what
the no sayers tell you all the time
that we couldn't do it
that you there i went through a thousand
times  first of all they laugh at
you because
secondly they say
the market is much too small for that and
then they say how long they've
known each other back then i already worked with him and
you're not close you don't mean
don't let yourself go either
tell society why you ca
n't do it like i said if you don't
do it but someone will do it
and the best thing is if you
do it and don't make it that's
just part of the process
yes if you have a one percent chance
try 100 times
[music]
in hamburg
about 40 he is definitely you know the ground zero in new york
mainz dpa tmn have the film immediately
is is jaedicke june future gives to
know d  ass youtube in the five
years that's important but that we
unfortunately spend 90 percent of our
time preparing ourselves in our lives we go to
school preparing ourselves when I
grow up I want to be an entrepreneur
then I'll be at the university I'll prepare
myself  learn things then i'm out and
work somewhere and prepare myself
maybe there will be a message about it
he prepares you all the time but
you only do maximum in ten percent of the cases
what you actually
prepare for and that's what i call activity
level turning  that's about 90 percent and
thinks ten percent prepare you
ten percent challenge him
that's also extremely important that
fits in perfectly right now as if I
had already prepared it business pc
industry
the industry
[music]
although I've always had one  vision
yes the vision should be realistic
you don't want to do such
nonsensical things now or if you
achieve it then it's worth nothing  big
goals think big but also remain realistic
but the vision will not lead you to the
goal what will lead you to the goal
it's a very important thing that i've
learned myself is just a
plan for the next day what i'll do tomorrow in my
calendar are the last ones  five
minutes planned to get up in the morning this
meeting the meeting hand in these documents
do this do it says in there that
is my ossi the city knows
you always give them i have even if
the remote control is somehow so obliquely
open technology carries through then it has to
be straight  yes that's positive just
try something like that or stop what she
actually listens to something
that means god be it the parents be it
oh she tries to translate that into a
feasible task even the worst
flaws listen to someone
i knew one  being a person but
trying to translate this listening to something on it
so if you are extremely
strict with yourself  says I'll go
crazy if I
don't do my tasks today or tomorrow and
would then have to postpone these tasks from tomorrow
to the day after tomorrow that there will
be a lot more the day after tomorrow
and then the point will come if you
don't care that she didn't
make it because that's what you wanted  not nobody at all
and that's also important
whether I do it or whether you do it
or you do it the universe
doesn't care at
all rainer wirtz do you not only
decided not to do it yourself you don't
actually need
me to be sitting here today for that  think to yourself talk to
you and you already know how important that
is but realize that
just tells me i will just do it then
look at a calendar and see how much
you have really achieved and set
this big goal or this big
vision translates that into realizable
tasks
there can't be in there tomorrow with
you an empire up well what do
I
do I don't see any task if tomorrow
it says in it or it says in it for tomorrow
tomorrow i'll meet this gentleman
who will help me i'll do 100
sales talks that can be implemented
that will get you to your goal that's not a
sprint that's a marathon and in
between you have sprints that
means every day before planned and right
be strict with you
before
euro
[music]
is the smi lx
[applause]
was also the organizer in the past and if
nobody was there at the event there
were errors was just bad the good
thing nobody noticed was nobody
that it's a business like that  if
it is not successful next because you
have another example yes if she
plays basketball and takes a ball
and takes a shot yes because many say it
is risky to start a business and something like
that if they have a shot
and you don't hit and stop it that is risky
but if i say hey i will shoot 100 times
that it is not risky if the
1 percent has to be successful
then try it 100 times  means
don't be afraid of the mistakes
[music]